Hey there, so I've got one more sort
of lingering question in my mind.
I know we're using all these
Firebase UI classes for
basically everything in
the app to do with lists.
But I'm confused why Firebase array
doesn't just grab an array list.
Hey, looks like J.P.'s texting me,
and he wants me to go to Google and
talk to a Firebase expert.
Well that's pretty cool,
but I'm not free.
I told Kagure I'd cheer her on in
the finals of the Cheesy Flakes
cheddar cheese cook off championships.
Hm, but you're available right?
Why don't you head over there right
now and report back what you learn.
want to borrow the company bike?
[MUSIC]
>> So
how does Firebase treat lists in arrays?
>> So, lists in Firebase
deviate a little from the traditional
array concept you're used to.
The big difference is in Firebase,
we always have these key value pairs.
That value might be an object with more
keys so you can have this hierarchical
structure, but
it's always a key and a value.
An array in a traditional situation
is a key value pair where the key is
an integer, and the pair is whatever
data is stored in that array.
Firebase doesn't quite like that.
You can put in integer keys,
you can make an exact normal
array structure in your Firebase.
But when you're building real time
applications that deal with information
that's changing quickly, or a lot of
new information that's being added.
There's a really good chance that
two people are going to try and
add the same new integer
key at the same time.
So if we have four items and
then somebody adds a fifth,
and another person across the planet
adds a fifth, one of those people
are going to win and the other
one's going to lose their data.
That's why in Firebase,
we use this concept of pushing
in with these unique push ids.
These are pretty much globally unique
identifiers that will be sorted in
the same way as integer keys, where if I
push in later it will appear later and
they essentially function like an array.
The only difference is
instead of having one, two,
three, four as our keys,
we have these long complicated stings.
But once it's in there you can pull
the data out, you can look through it,
you can do everything you
would on a normal array.
Especially if you're using
one of our helper libraries.
It's just the structure looks a little
bit different in your Firebase.
>> So
why did Firebase take this approach.
>> It was mostly our concern for
the real time aspect.
We wanted to make it really easy to
build data that multiple people were
editing and
collaborating on at the same time.
And like I said, you can run into these
race conditions where you have multiple
people trying to add onto the same list.
And the integers,
it's just too likely that two people
will write to it at the same time.
Using these unique keys,
we can guarantee that if two people, or
100 people in the world will write
to this location at the same time,
they're not,
no one's going to lose their data.
No one's going to get
overwritten by someone else,
they'll all be unique,
all the data will be there.
And you can ensure that all your users
interactions will be safely stored in
Firebase.
>> So what are some of the pros and
cons of this approach?
>> Well the con is that
it's a little unusual.
People are used to dealing
with lists as arrays,
they're used to those integer keys.
And when people look at their data
in Firebase they see this familiar
push method that comes
in any of our SDKs, and
they assume it's going to
act like a normal array.
Which for many reasons it does, but
the big change is that
we use these unique IDs.
So, that's probably the real
big difference that people see,
is just that, it's a little unnatural.
But as soon as you realize why
we make these decisions, and
why we're helping you to make sure
that your application scales and
runs efficiently at any size,
then it makes a lot of sense.
>> Well, are there any times that
you need to use an array, and
how would you do it?
>> There are definitely times people
want to use arrays, and it typically has
to do when you're integrating with
an older system, or some existing
application that is very committed
to using these traditional arrays.
And you can do that in Firebase, you
can use integer keys in your Firebase,
it's completely fine.
The important part to remember is
just that if you have a lot of people
writing to this data at the same time,
trying to change that array,
trying to add in new things,
you're going to run into issues.
But if you have, for example,
a dot net application that
every 24 hours it's pushing in a list
of your top 100 users into Firebase,
you can use normal integer keys just
like a normal array, and that's fine.
because you only have your one
server ever writing into Firebase.
There's not going to be
any erase conditions,
there's not going to
be anything like that.
So that's completely okay.
And Firebase does do some handling to
help transition that into a normal
looking array, especially if you're
exporting JSON through our traditional
rest API, which is what you would be
doing if you were using dot net or
any PHP,
any of these more traditional stacks.
So yeah, there are definitely
situations where you can do it, and
we support those,
we just generally don't recommend it for
any quickly changing,
quickly moving data.
>> Now you mentioned push IDs,
how are push IDs generated, and
what makes them so great?
So push IDs can be thought
of as a globally unique ID,
they're not a traditional GUid
that you've seen before, but for
all intents and
purposes they are completely unique,
and they're a little magical in that
they're lexigraphically sorted.
Which means that if I push in now,
and I call it pushing in later,
it will sort as you'd expect,
it'll come later in the list.
We do that by basing it off of
the time of when you pushed in,
we look at an apec.
And we say, okay, what is a nice version
of this that we know will sort properly.
And then we also add in some
extra logic on top of that to
make sure there are no collisions.
So if I have a server running
that's pushing in 10,000 items,
we make sure that, even if you push
those all in on the exact same
millisecond from the same machine,
there will be no collisions.
So it is a lot of logic behind it,
but the important part is they're just
strings that will lexographically
sort in the correct order.
And they're so
great just because they avoid all
your race condition problems that you
might have using traditional arrays.
>> Well Abe, thanks a lot for your time.
I think it's going to
really help my friend out.
I think she's going to
be able to continue to
developing your Firebase app,
and, yeah, appreciate it.
>> Awesome, thanks so much.